lo que he tratado de dibujar aquí es un
círculo unitario
círculo
un unitario
y los llama unitarios porque tiene un
radio de valor 1 la longitud desde el
centro de este eje que por cierto este
círculo está centrado en el origen hacia
cualquier punto de la circunferencia va
a ser igual a 1 así que cuál será la
coordenada de este punto que intersecta
a la circunferencia en el eje bueno la
longitud de aquí hasta acá va a ser
igual a 1 la coordenada va a ser va a
ser x igual a 1 ye igual a 0
cuál será la coordenada de este punto de
acá bueno la coordenada aquí va a ser x
igual a 0 y ya va a ser igual a 1
la coordenada de este otro punto de acá
como ustedes pueden ver va a ser 1 pero
en el lado negativo del eje x así que va
a ser menos 1
y ya va a ser igual a cero finalmente
este último punto de aquí abajo tiene un
1 pero en el eje negativo del h por lo
que va a ser bueno primero la coordenada
x va a ser igual a 0 y el valor en que
es menos 1
aquí tenemos todas las coordenadas
principales de este círculo unitario y
ya que aclaramos esto voy a dibujar un
ángulo y para esto voy a establecer una
convención para los ángulos positivos
voy a establecer que un ángulo positivo
si yo establezco que este lado que estoy
dibujando aquí este lado rosa es el
inicio del ángulo el punto de partida un
ángulo positivo va a ser aquel que voy a
dibujar en sentido antihorario es decir
que va a ir hacia acá en este sentido
entonces un ángulo positivo es aquel que
tiene sentido
sentido
en ti
horario
antihorario
es la convención que usaremos y que
normalmente se usa en todas partes con
respecto a estos ángulos se podrán
imaginar que un ángulo negativo un
ángulo negativo puede tendrá su sentido
horario irá en sentido
sentido horario
en el mismo sentido que las manecillas
del reloj
vamos a dibujar un ángulo positivo aquí
comencé con esta flechita y el ángulo
positivo va a llegar más o menos aquí
este es mi ángulo positivo y lo voy a
llamar theta lo que quiero hacer es
pensar en este punto de intersección
entre la línea del ángulo y la
circunferencia
y digamos que este punto va a tener unas
coordenadas a b
el objetivo de lo que estoy haciendo
aquí es como este círculo unitario
podría ayudarnos a extender nuestras
definiciones trigonométricas quiero
hacer que este ángulo theta sea parte de
un triángulo rectángulo así que vamos a
dibujar lo que nos haría falta para
convertirlo en un triángulo rectángulo
que es hacer una línea recta acá
aquí tener un ángulo de 90 grados veamos
si podemos calcular los lados del
triángulo mi primera pregunta para
ustedes es cuál es el valor de la
hipotenusa pues la hipotenusa es el
radio de este círculo unitario y vale 1
así que esto vale 1 y cuál será la
longitud de este lado de aquí arriba
de aquí a acá
bueno pues va a ser la longitud que
tenga en el eje de las 10 y viendo las
coordenadas pues va a vélez de este lado
vale ve finalmente cuál va a ser el
valor de este lado que está aquí abajo
que voy a dibujar o resaltar en azul
oscuro este lado de acá pues va a tener
el valor de la coordenada x es decir va
a valer
ahora que tenemos todo establecido cuál
será el coseno del ángulo theta cuál
será el co seno del ángulo t cual será
este valor
pues para esto vamos a usar nuestro
neumónicos ok a toda su k
que justamente estamos en proceso de
expandir así que de éste no mónico la
parte que nos interesa para resolver
nuestra pregunta es la de caja el coste
no es igual al cateto adyacente la
hipotenusa la longitud del cateto
adyacente es a lo vimos aquí del
adyacente a nuestro ángulo teta por lo
que el coseno del ángulo teta es igual
al adyacente que es la letra a de
nuestra coordenada entre la hipotenusa
que vale 1 por lo que el coche no
detecta va a ser igual a a por lo que es
igual a la coordenada x del punto de
intersección conoce circunferencia
ahora pensemos en el caso de seno de
teta
seno del ángulo theta
vemos de nuestras definiciones
vamos a usar ahora sol que es igual al
cateto opuesto entre la hipotenusa
nuestro cateto opuesto es b la
hipotenusa sigue siendo 1 por lo que el
pse no va a ser igual a b a la
coordenada en ya que interesante las
coordenadas de este punto de
intersección entre el ángulo y la
circunferencia unitaria también la
podemos ver como el coche no detecta
coma
el seno seno de eta
ahora podremos utilizar este círculo
unitario para mejorar nuestro soca tohá
ya que este tiene un problema pues
funciona bien cuando nuestro ángulo es
mayor a 0 y menor a 90 grados ya que
siempre podemos convertirlo en un
triángulo rectángulo pero no nos va a
funcionar cuando el ángulo sea negativo
o cuando sea mayor a 90 grados trata de
ilustrar lo aquí imaginemos que tenemos
aquí un triángulo rectángulo y queremos
que este ángulo vaya siendo más grande
entonces vamos a poder hacer seguir
haciendo triángulos rectángulos pero va
a llegar un momento en el que pues
aunque queramos no vamos a poder tener
un triángulo con dos ángulos de 90
grados y en este punto es cuando deja de
funcionar zocato
y más aún cuando tenemos ángulos que son
mayores a 90 grados
veamos si podemos usar lo que tenemos
aquí para encontrar una nueva definición
de las funciones trigonométricas como
extensión de soca tohá en lugar de hacer
referencia a triángulos rectángulos
ahora vamos a usar esta convención para
establecer la referencia con respecto a
un círculo unitario ya que siempre voy a
poder dibujar un ángulo dentro de un
círculo unitario
vamos que el coseno del ángulo theta lo
voy a escribir aquí abajo el coseno de
la anglo teta es igual a la coordenada
x
donde donde el lado
terminal
final
del ángulo del ángulo
intersecta al círculo
intersecta intersecta
al círculo
y esta es mi definición de coseno de
teta con respecto a un círculo unitario
y también definimos que el seno del
ángulo teta va a ser igual a la
coordenada en donde el lado terminal del
ángulo intersecta al círculo
esencialmente para cualquier ángulo en
este punto de intersección entre el
ángulo y la circunferencia este punto va
a definir el seno y el coche no de teta
y qué pasa con la definición de tangente
de teta bueno la tangente de teta del
soca todas podemos ver que es el lado
opuesto entre el lado adyacente por lo
tanto esto va a ser igual al coseno de
teta que es el lado opuesto entre el
lado adyacente que es el seno
beteta
que en este caso viene siendo igual a la
coordenada y entre la coordenada x en
siguientes vídeos veremos ejemplos de
cómo usar esta definición del círculo
unitario para evaluar algunas razones
trigonométricas